and do you have any particular leaf
particular favorite characters or
episodes within this I mean the dance of
the Dragons of course it sort of forms
in a sense a core part of the book well
I have I have a lot of affection from
mushroom well say a little bit about
mushroom and send and link it if you
wouldn't mind to the process of writing
fake history because this is something
that really struck me that you've done
so skillfully with this book explaining
mushroom is maybe well mushroom is a
dwarf and but he's not a well born one
like Tyrion he's he's a dwarf of lowly
birth who's the the fool at in the court
during the events leading up to and
during much of the dance of the Dragons
and it's aftermath he's a jester they
were actually a number of jesters in the
real middle ages of course you've
probably seen them in many movies fools
gestures as they were called some of
them were very very clever men who were
who could do all sorts of wit witticisms
and and jokes who could sing funny songs
who could juggle and ride unicycles and
do other colorful things some of them
were people who were physically deformed
were word Dwarfs or hunchbacks or
whatever and some of them were and
obviously very politically incorrect
these days but some of them were
mentally handicapped mentally [ __ ]
the people of the Middle Ages found that
wonderfully amusing so much room is is a
dwarf but he's of the clever sorties and
and he's an observer and he the
testimony of mushroom this is this folks
not actually written by me you see it's
written by archmaester gil Dane of the
Citadel and he's writing a history and
like anyone writing a history he has to
go back to primary sources and I had a
lot of fun with that because when he
gets to the dance of dragons he has a
number of primary sources but three of
them are most major he has he is Grand
Master or wilds official court records
he
as the Septon who was kept the cept in
King's Landing and the red cape who of
course is a is a religious figure so he
interprets everything as the will of the
gods and what was a sin and what wasn't
this thing and he has mushroom who was
semi-literate and couldn't actually
write anything but who told his story in
later years to to a equivalent of a monk
who wrote it all down and mushroom story
of course is always the most scandalous
Gorillaz filthy version of events all of
which had to do with people betraying
each other and poisoning each other and
having similar type fun and sleeping in
place of station and sleep and all of
that I love the idea since this was a
fake history I didn't want to tell it as
a omniscient historian sitting down this
is what actually happened I loved the
idea of telling it as a historian in
world who's trying to figure out what
happened but he's looking better his
primary sources and he's finding
contradictory accounts you know and this
was impressed on me many many years ago
long before Game of Thrones began I was
I was writing a novel that was never
completed or published it was black and
white and red all vermin novel about
1890s journalism in New York City when
there were fourteen competing daily
newspapers one of which was the New York
world owned and operated by Joseph
Pulitzer it's a great great journalist
for whom two Pulitzer Prizes named and
the New York world building which no
longer exists but was down on Park Row
which is where all the newspapers who
were built was the tallest building in
the world at its time and it had a
golden dome on the top it was a very
memorable building you know it was built
right next to the Sun a competing paper
but it was so high that people said pull
occur could could lean out and spit on
the Sun if you wanted to spit straight
down at a smaller building next one
the thing is when I tried to research
the world and find out tallest building
in the world how many stories was that
exactly I found three different
contradictory citations it was easy is
20 stories tall or 16 I think were 15
and that really impressed on me this is
like 1890 I'm looking at this is like
yesterday incomparable things this is a
simple factual question how many stories
were in this building and I'm getting
three different accounts if they can't
even get that right
what's the odds that they know what
happened to Charlemagne you know 2,000
years ago or something the answer
astronomical so modern historian or
something like archmaester gilding has
to sort through these stories these
contradictory stories and decide which
he believes in which he doesn't believe
and I had a lot of fun being able to
tell you know mushrooms accounts which
are probably all turned up to 37 and
then the dollar accounts but I didn't
have to just stick to the dollar
accounts I could give all three and that
was a great deal of fun and gilding sort
of favor phrase that he he comes back to
is I guess we'll never know after after
presenting every version of the story
and in this beautifully some Peruvians
but that kind of buttoned up surely when
you're reading your actual histories you
would encounter the same problems
exactly the same thing so you do the
same thing you know you tell the
obviously phony version the go but
that's probably phony but by that time
you've got the bit about the red-hot
poker up the arse or
[Laughter]